مظاهر الاحتفال
الموالين لحزب العداله والتنميه بداوا
بالنزول الى الشارع بداوا بالاحتفال
بالنصر طبعا بعد قليل سنكون امام خطاب
النصر الذي سيلقيه اردوغان من
طبعا ليس من مقر حزب العداله والتنميه
وانما
سيلقيه من المكان الذي سيكرس فيه اردوغان
بالولايه الجديده رئيسا لكل تركيا وليس
فقط لحزب العداله والتنميه نظرا مشاهدينا
لما تحدثنا عنه من انتصار للقوميه التركيه
ومن التغير الطارئ الذي تغير على المشهد
التركي لاحظنا الاحزاب القوميه التركيه
كيف حجزت لنفسه اماكن متقدمه ان كان
بالبرلمان وان كان بالتحالفات وان كانت
يعني ترجيح كافه النصر لاي من الافرقه
اتحدث هنا عن
سنان اوغان الذي حصل على نسبه ليست
بالقليله وطبعا قام بدعم اردوغان بجوله
الاعاده الثانيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات